[Music]
let's go to lynn in philadelphia we're
born and raised
in playgrounds
most of my days what's up
hi dr john thanks so much for taking my
call of course thanks for calling how
are you this morning
i'm okay um i have a question i'm hoping
i can get some guidance and advice from
you i will do the best i can and if i
answer it terribly we're just going to
edit it out and no one will even know
this call happened which is so good so
right now only you and your friends will
be like i call that guy he's an idiot
so what's up
so my question is how to parent through
my 15 year old daughter expressing a
desire to reach out to her birth father
who is my ex-husband who is not a safe
person and has not been in her life or
mine since she's been born
yikes
so
when you say not a safe person let's
start there that's a big one
yeah so um
so obviously from my perspective as uh
married to him there was repeated
unfaithfulness verbal emotional abuse
but beyond that there was also a
sustained pornography addiction
throughout our marriage that i found out
during the marriage and then that
escalated to
um pornography with kids or at least
with pre-teen girls looking at porn yeah
i found when we were
he's not
what happened when that came to light
that he was into child pornography
so i mean remember this is almost 20
years ago i was in my early 20s i found
it on the computer
and i didn't understand at that point
like oh i need to call the police i
understand that now
i didn't i instead got in touch with um
you know a counselor or a therapist
through church and he did go a little
bit but it didn't really
seem to help and he wasn't invested in
that
and so in my mind um naively i kind of
lumped all of that evilness together
as just oh this is more of his
pornography addiction i know now
like i'm a licensed foster parent i'm
trauma informed i understand that that
is a reportable offense but like since
it's so long ago
and it was like on a home computer that
no longer exists like i haven't reported
anything
about him and i haven't been in touch
with him in like 15 years
so before the day is over
you got to make a report
okay
you have to do that
okay
um the
yeah you have to for
the kids caught up in that stuff
for
um
yeah he got to
okay
yeah you got to make that call today um
and you can let them know i know this is
20 years ago
i
know that 20 years ago i should have
made this call
um and i didn't and here we are and so i
need to report this and i would also be
honest and say i also know that i've got
a 15 year old daughter who's asking
questions about her dad and this looks
bad
yeah and
oh you're going to get me all riled up
man um i know no
the
so
even if
i give you grace for 20 years ago you're
in the middle of a storm and you're in a
mess and this is all lumped into a big
pot
the fact that y'all took this to a
church building and they sat on it makes
me insane
right and to be honest i don't know i
mean i wasn't part of those uh
counseling sessions i don't know how
much was shared
other than you know i'm a you know he
was addicted to porn i don't know if he
went into what type or
anything like that again like in my head
at the time it was all
kind of a blur like we got divorced when
i was pregnant with my now 15 year old
daughter so i was just
a mess
understand he was seeing an 18 year old
at the time that i found out when i was
a few months pregnant and then i found
pornography and it was just all a big
blur
um for me right
um but yeah
but i i hear you and i get it make that
call now i i i know in a number of
states they've passed there is no
statute of limitations on that okay and
in fact
in a couple of states where i've got
connections it's a crime to not
okay report not report it okay well this
we were in tennessee at the time
yeah wherever it happens to be um
it's a crime to not report it
and i think in texas they just said if
you know about it and don't report it
you will be fired from whatever job you
are happen to be working
for and you're subject to criminals
tough so it's okay yeah make the call
um even if they raid his computer and
there's nothing on it and he's a changed
person
the the
the downside to that is he has an
inconvenient day
uh or he's subject to an investigation
that finds that nothing's going on
otherwise
we're gonna protect some children right
okay
um
when it comes to your daughter what's
what's her
does he even want to talk to her is he
responding back to her what's the deal
here
or she just haven't she just has
questions
she has questions right so i saw in her
browsing history she was looking him up
researching him
you know um throughout her life if ever
she's asked questions i've answered but
i haven't given more information than
needed
but now that she's older
we we talked about it pretty recently
and i was she wanted all the details so
i was pretty upfront with her including
um about the pornography and so forth um
and so after all that a day or two later
out of the blue she said just so you
know at some point i want to reach out
to him of course and and so i just i you
know i tried to keep like don't freak
out face on and i just said well you
know well got it what are you hoping to
what are you hoping happens or what do
you
what are you hoping to accomplish type
of question and he she just said i have
questions yeah
absolutely and so i said okay got it and
so here's the big question
here's a big question
what was it about me
that you walked away
from right what was it about all those
other girls what was it about all the
other women what was it about the your
addictions what was it about your
depression your whatever
that was so much more important than me
i just need to know that
and yeah
and so
on you gave her
that that curiosity that creativity that
desire to know herself and
you've been on trauma-informed journeys
you're learning you
do
you
love and care for foster kids that that
who in my question is foundational to
all of us
so her desire to just know some stuff
uh is real and in her 15 year old brain
her desire to tell him what he thinks is
real too
that's in 45 year old brains i'm gonna
find him and i'm just gonna tell him
that
it never does anything but it feels like
it's gonna feel good
so all those questions are good
right now
the last contact you've had
is with a felon
and as the mother of a 15 year old you
must protect your daughter
right and so it's okay to say your
questions are super legit
you ask me anything
but in the same way you would not let
her connect with a 35 or 45 year old
person on the sex offender registry list
she doesn't get contact in that that
level of boundary i don't care that it
happens to be her dad
okay
and you can let her know in that
uncertain terms i have not spoken to
this man in 20 years and last i knew he
was very unsafe
i wouldn't let a strange child around
him i'm not gonna let you
also one thing that she can do is write
letters to him that she doesn't mail she
doesn't have his address but she can
hang on
when you make this call have you not
spoken to him for two decades or 15
years um it's been about 13 years
because i did end up getting sole
custody a year or two into her life okay
and so that's when we last had contact
through child pornography didn't come up
during the their custody hearing
um we didn't really have it didn't no it
didn't go through a hearing like that he
basically said he was not going to visit
her and so his rights went down to he
can only contact her through writing
right now he's not allowed to visit her
or anything and it wasn't
he just said he wasn't going to
and so we just started all through a
mediator yeah it was all through a
mediator we didn't go before a judge at
all okay for a hearing
i haven't heard of mediated
parental rights being terminated before
but maybe i don't i don't know about it
his parental yeah his rights aren't
terminated
so he's on paper he's still her father
but he can't he's not by law allowed to
visit her he's only allowed to
um communicate with her in writing
that's where it was left when
like 13 years ago
and so i want to i know he is your
ex-husband i know he's her dad
but i want you to listen to what you're
saying
and i want to challenge you that your
daughter needs you now
because on paper
he still has the ability to communicate
with her
and he's a sex offender
right
yep
i know that's so hard i know this brings
up every demon on earth in your soul
and i also know that you know these
things
how long has that been haunting you that
he's gonna reach out that has to have
been a ghost that's been chasing you for
15 years um
i've always been scared that she would
want to reach out to him not so much
that he would reach out to her
um think of think of her reaching out to
him as less about him and more about her
trying to find out who she is
this is this is an exploration to find
herself and it's got to go through him
right and that's and i get that and and
she's kind of going through the stage
where she's pushing against a lot of
boundaries now right
right right right i get it right so this
is another one and so i want to be
careful like
my fear is in setting a boundary of no
no communication no nothing that she's
just going to try to find a way around
it right she's easy enough to find
online 1000 she will
yeah and what would you do
if your daughter was doing what she
could to communicate
with somebody that you knew
was addicted to child pornography
what would you do
i'll tell you what you would do anything
you'd cut the wi-fi you'd throw every
computer in the dumpster
okay
yeah
you would go to
you would go to hell and back to keep
your daughter away from that guy that
guy just happens to be her dad
right
and that's why this stuff has to be
formalized you've got to make a report
it's got to be written down
and you've still got access to you still
have his social security number and his
stuff and all that and there's going to
be some shame on your part for not
reporting it expect that yeah 100
and at some point you're going to let
yourself you're going to have to forgive
yourself and go forward and not continue
to be anchored to i should have i should
have i should have in the past you
didn't so here we are
right
i would also
recommend
your daughter's gonna look for any way
this quest to figure out who she is is
it's universal we all go through it
she is going to
look for ways
that you are the bad guy here which
gives her permission to break your
boundaries
okay
so
there is a difference between saying
this man was sick
this man was an addict
this man got into some evil stuff and
there's a difference between that and i
hate this guy this guy's great
and so the best you can
keep it about facts and data and not
about your opinions
yes does that make sense and that way
yeah it will not it it will it's going
to turn that anyway you just don't like
him or you're just mad that he fill in
the blank that's expect that but that
way there's never that sliver of she's
holding out on me
right
this is
yeah and i've certainly tried to never
ever
say he's bad he just sees that
she would ask me when she was younger if
he was bad and i said you know he's just
sad and he needs healing and he's made
bad choices but i never i try to never
villainize i think it's very fair to say
he's very very sick
and there will come a moment
when your daughter will look you in the
eye and say why didn't you call
mm-hmm
and you're gonna have to be honest with
her says screw that right
yep it should have been i didn't i
messed up and that will never
ever
ever happen again
i hate this for you lynn i hate all of
it i hate it for those little girls
involved in the pornography stuff
i hate it for
your daughters had to grow up with a dad
who just cashed out
oh man
if you know and i'm telling everybody
now
if you know of somebody
who's involved in child pornography
call
today
period full stop end of story
conversation over call today
if you know somebody who's hurting kids
call today
if you know somebody who's neglecting
their kids call them today
those kids deserve better than that and
they need all of us
call today
man
and lin you're gonna have to
take a big breath
go do some hard stuff you're you have to
set that shame down your daughter needs
you daughter needs you
just protect our kids good folks let's
protect our kids